oh great huh oh that's good oh oh good
oh this is Grace sleep well tonight ha
ha ha is this happening to you as well
sucks right hi servers are broken for
many but in the meantime there are new
additions to GTA online from the high
sup date that you may not know about it
here's a rundown on some ways to kill
time and prep for your marathon of heist
before anything else time to get dolled
up stroll down to your local clothing
outlet and try on tons of new heist
related outfits and accessories
customize your bod without fit styles
like the uptight minimalist will roll
out of bed with this sloppy one plan on
being the wheelman for your crew slip on
these new driving gloves to really seal
the deal next stop ammunation not much
to show off here other than this flare
gun used in one of the heist missions
this baby won't take down any vehicles
but it can cause some deep burns on some
cops
so you're locked and loaded time to make
some easy doe daily objectives bring
further purpose to GTA online's free
roam start your morning cup of joe with
objectives like participating in a team
deathmatch job going to the movies or
maybe a simple play related objective
like hiring a mugger on another player
knock off your daily 3 and score up to
25,000 big ones unfortunately in order
to access hot new vehicles like the
Hydra you'll need to complete the
corresponding heist for instance
finishing the first hice allows you to
purchase the armored car kuruma which
runs for about half a mil there are
however other newly added cars or you'll
probably be better off saving and
waiting for the big ones also you can
now point double tap the right stick to
get your point across
if you're in between heists rockstar
brings adversary modes here's hasta la
vista to two teams one team on bicycles
are tasked with racing down the hill to
the finish line ah there's a catch two
rooks the other team is tasked with
annihilating cyclists with big rig
trucks frantically racing downhill
looking behind you and seeing these
trucks gaining on you is absolutely
exhilarating hit a jump throw in some
cheap moves to fake them out oh it's a
standoff I see you buddy oh how sweet
he's letting me back on again alright
and playing as the trucker's is tricky
as you're constantly balancing speed
with control hey where's my other
teammate oh my man it's tough but pull
off a solid ram oh it's fantastic so
that's what you've got to keep yourself
busy you know we've waited this long
let's just try and keep it together and
just wait a little bit longer we can't
have anyone freaking out just gotta wait
a little bit longer right away what a
play which is lovely
you